later this month Donald Trump is going
to make his first foreign trip as
president first foreign trip yeah
yeah that's right he's visiting a
library
[Applause]
Oh get out of here you guys are like you
Joker
he is though he is gonna be traveling
soon later this month president Trump
will visit Israel Saudi Arabia and the
Vatican yeah
Trump said I look forward to insulting
three religions in one trip it's
efficient you get to each one what else
is going on oh this was big news has
been announced that 95 year old Prince
Philip the husband of Queen Elizabeth is
going to retire from his royal duties
this fall yeah and the Queen said well
not all his royal duties
sex I went too far I apologize Facebook
in the news Facebook is hiring 3,000 new
people to scan its website all day
looking for offensive or obscene content
yeah now Mark Zuckerberg if you're
watching Andy has been training for this
job
[Music]
I mean you know we have such fast
internet I know I know we do have fast
internet this is interesting in New
Mexico in New Mexico a high school
science teacher was arrested for making
meth yes yeah he faces 25 years in
prison and up to 12 Emmy Awards it could
happen
that's a true story a new study just
came out a new study just came out
suggests that giving toddlers under the
age of two a smartphone to kind of play
with may stunt their development yeah in
response tired parents everywhere said
shut
we clearly have some parents here well
my kids were that age if it would shut
him up I'd have given him more uranium
yeah
[Music]
you